shits creeks Annie Murphy stops by the
Kelly Clarkson show today and told Kelly
that she almost quit acting before
landing the role of Alexis on the show I
can't even imagine shits Creek without
any where no that's like she's such a
massive part of the show and one of her
characters most iconic moments in season
six is the amazing performance of her
song a little bit Alexis well Kelly and
Annie performed the song together today
on the show and Kelly even added her own
first take a look at this
[Music]
a little bit I'm a classic Bronco this
time I'm a whole lot of tipsy when I
drink fine wine
I got likes money jobs it's not talk a
lot I'm a whole lot married my man so
hard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's really good yeah I like the Kelly
added her own verse to it as well with
Texas references of it but yeah like I
can't picture shits Creek without any
Murphy on oh no no not at all
that is I love that so much and I love
that the show is just and I love that
the show because it's never it's in its
last season coming up that everybody is
now just sort of getting on board and
you can feel the sort of pain with
people because they're just discovering
how good it is knowing that it will be
gone very soon but they are so smart to
end it oh no I know I you know what I
mean a lot of shows go on for way too
long and it just they fall off the rails
but like Danny new gene deciding to end
the show where they're ending it it is
brilliant yeah and it will be perfect
like it will be it's its thing and it'll
live on and it will always have fans and
but I liked it now they're getting all
this I mean they did a long time they
went a long time without doing things
like Kelly Clarkson without doing things
like the SAG Awards without doing all
this stuff and then you know it just it
clicked like it just started to just
started to work for them and I think
it's great I love them all and I like
there's some good people there are all
good people on that show yeah